so
potential
oh
sorry to keep you waiting
but i promise
it
will be worth it
on behalf of the organizers
welcome to this town hall meeting with
the president of france and the prime
minister of denmark
rasmussen
as lisa told you my name is luige
and you must also be very happy because
look obviously danish means happiness
because you are the ones who secured
yourself seats for this event which
according to somebody on twitter was
sold on or sold out faster than the
rolling stones here in copenhagen
despite the fact that we
are going to have a very serious
discussion on
europe
and there can hardly be any time
since the second world war where it's
more important for us to discuss europe
how shall we respond to the new message
from the president of the united states
that europe is at least with regards to
trade and enemy
are we and i'm sure we'll touch upon
this topic today gaining or losing
sovereignty when we strengthen eu
integration what about the immigration
crisis how to react there what about the
election to the european parliament
what kind of election
are we supposed to think about there and
what kind of impact we'll have upon
europe
i could go on but uh please start to
think yourself because this is supposed
to be an interactive
meeting if you want to ask a question
please raise your hand and wait for the
microphone and i have some assistance
could you just wave woo the nice
assistance then you try to see whether
you catch their attention state your
name and affiliation
but we are not the only ones
participating because we have almost 30
libraries all over denmark who are
basically now also watching this event
and you can also send your questions and
then we'll put them on the live screen
up here so henning
bonjour and since we have no translation
in here this will be
basically the only french we'll use
today
so this is not the time or the place for
you to show off the french you learned
in school on your summer vacation or
sort of when you had a french girlfriend
but please
do remember to learn languages french
german spanish and so forth because
languages are obviously crucial
also for the future
when you asked your question please be
brief
be concrete and stick to one question
and do remember that a question ends
with a question mark
so this is not the place either where
you demonstrate your own analytical
skills
our respect to your fellow students or
neighbor who would also like to ask a
question
our two speakers
and they are almost about to arrive
we'll start with two short interventions
and then we move to question time and
obviously we will all rise
also for
once we get here for the his royal
highness the crown prince of denmark
and also then suspense we wait
and only in a few minutes we will have
the president of france uh with us
obviously also prime minister of denmark
so let's just wait a couple of minutes
[Applause]
so
so
so
it's not true when people claim that
students are not silent
but most of them are obviously always
from the university of copenhagen
time to start a tap dance
sort of competition because something
will happen very soon
[Applause]
i think we can stop please rise
royal highness the crown prince of
denmark
the president of france
and the prime minister of denmark and
now to start to clap let's see what
happens
[Applause]
come on over there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and we keep on clapping
and we can also use our feet
that's something must happen eventually
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
so oh
classroom
thank you ever so much for coming
thank you
you came thank you very much
i was about to sing i was about to tap
dance and these are not my strengths so
your chat danced i tried mission replies
or not states minister i'm tempted to
start this meeting by saying welcome
home
as denmark's prime minister
and not to forget alumni of this
university you are obviously by
definition at home
but so are you mr president
i spent my childhood in books you have
said
and here you are
in the royal danish library
and i understand that you are still very
much a book person
indeed to such an extent that one of
your grandchildren after you gave her
yet another book for her birthday
remarked you know toy stories do exist
you have studied philosophy
and here you are at an event
co-organized by the university of
surrenkirca the university of copenhagen
and just a few minutes ago together with
the prime minister you saw some of
kiko's original handwritten manuscripts
here at the library
and politically you also at home
because in a new book
you have defined yourself as a liberal
in the nordic sense
and here we see so when you arrive at
the library
according to your brilliant ambassador
and i see him down there
you are furthermore in the only country
in europe france has never been at war
with if we disregard the vikings
and mr president just to prove our
friendship
we played a nil nil draw
during the world cup
in russia in football
that by the way was the only match le
bleu didn't win
so some of us right
[Applause]
we we like to think that we want just a
tiny tiny tiny bit of your cooktomort
so
welcome statesman before we open for
questions and we'll take questions from
here and also from almost 30 libraries
and you are over there we have agreed
that the prime minister followed by the
president will give a short intervention
and like a strict former pro-rector
i mean
because we have many students who have
been waiting and they have so many
questions that they would like to ask
you
and as i told the audience before you
arrived the tickets for this town hall
meeting was sold out faster somebody
claimed than the rolling stones here in
copenhagen
but before i give you the floor mr prime
minister
please make sure but you had some time
to do that to mute your smartphones
we may not have banned smartphones as
they have done in school in france over
the summer but don't give the prime
minister any ideas so prime minister
floresos thank you so much
thank you so much luke i will do my
utmost to be as short as possible but
i have a few words i want to share with
you first of all you are royal highness
mr president your excellencies
dear students thank you all for
attending and sorry for for the delay
and i also want to thank the library for
hosting this event
and of course
most important i want to thank you
emanuel for being here you are a true
friend of denmark
men are born
and remain free and equal in rights
these are the very first words in the
declaration of the rights of the man and
of the citizen written in paris during
the french revolution more than 200
years ago
a declaration
composed by brave souls based on
the ideals of enlightenment
and adopted in time of change division
and uncertainty
mr president your visionary countrymen
left us with a priceless legacy
looking at the world today
jane's division and uncertainty seems to
occur once again
from the east aggressive actors who
claim to be democrats but act
like autocrats
not only in their own countries but in
other countries as well
from the south fanatics who claim to
speak and fight on behalf of the world
religion
but end up taking it as a hostage in a
fight they will never win
and to the west
most recently
our friends and allies in the land of
the three
suddenly striving for less free trade
and discarding international agreements
on trade on climate and human rights
so ladies and gentlemen i think time has
come time has come to ask ourselves
what kind of world do we want what kind
of values do we cherish
hateful speech or peaceful dialogue
further divisions or lasting unity
dark fear
or big dreams
i know what i believe in
but the past has proven
that the dark sides of humanity always
lie in weight and that the shining
european values cannot be taken for
granted
the present shows us that the
strongholds of freedom and democracy are
more fragile than we imagined
and looking into the future
i fear that europe might be the last
voice of reason
so you could ask
who takes the lead when it comes to free
trade who takes the lead when it comes
to international agreements who takes
the lead when it comes to humanitarian
assistance and development date who
takes the lead when it comes to data
security and consumer safety and answers
europe does
so if we want our european values to
prove
we must stand up for them and we must
stand together
and this is also the case when it comes
to one of the biggest challenges of our
time climate change
a challenge so big that it can only be
handled if we change the way our society
work produce and consume a challenge
so big that no country can handle it
alone so what we need is europe
uh is european cooperation
european determination and the vision to
act for the benefit of all of mankind
not only a certain kind of man
so like you have said mr president there
is no planet b
and that is true
but it's also a fact that we can in fact
save the planet if we work together and
this is one reason why i believe
european unity is important today as it
has ever been
and this is why
i insist even though it's difficult on
debating how our union can improve like
we do today
in my mind the union should be
influential on transnational issues such
as climate trade migration exchange of
ideas for instance
it is indeed a great idea
which is
to
which will benefit all of you personally
and also benefit our societies that
students
are able to travel and start in
universities all over europe on the
other hand the union should not
interfere on issues that each member
state can handle alone such as social
systems healthcare
primary education or and other issues
which belong at national level but most
important of all
the union must be the people's union
relevant for the people
wanted by the people because in the end
it is nothing by the people
brexit and i will
shortly close my remarks but but brexit
is a sad reminder
of what happened
what happens when politicians despite
facts
make europe escape gold for everything
bad
europe is not strong because we agree on
anything on everything it's strong
because we also accept to disagree
in a civilized way
and because we find peaceful solutions
to our common challenges
the goal has never been to overcome to
become one people but should be many
peoples
united in diversity
so ladies and gentlemen we live in time
of change and division
but the answer to division is never to
build wars
or always putting your own country first
the answer is to build bridges
to put freedom
to put responsibility and dialogue first
and i hope that we
who are gathered here today
will share that experience as well so i
look very much forward to a good
debate thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much prime minister
the author of the little prince once
wrote in life there are no solutions
they are forces on the move
create them and solutions follow quote
unquote so michelin president now we
look very much forward to the forces you
want to create in europe the floor is
yours and thank you very much for coming
thanks very much your wi-liners
mr prime minister your last
commissioner
dear friends ladies and gentlemen thanks
very much for being here and i mean i
like this opportunity to have a direct
discussion
on europe and especially with
your generation
europe was created by another generation
the founding fathers experienced war
that divided europe
and what they created is something
absolutely unique
it never happened to have 70 years more
than 70 years
without any war on this continent it's
unique
we never experienced that before
and they created something
which is for the very first time
was not based on hegemony
because it's not
the unity of europe on the basis of the
domination of one nation on the others
but a constant and permanent dialogue
between
equal member states
this is european union
it's a unique relationship with
no other region in the world
whereas this kind of creation exists
no other
and progressively decades after decades
probably
we forgot this
i mean the energy of the origins
and for your generation
war
seems to be something which could happen
far from your country but this is not a
reality of your day-to-day life here
and
a lot of the basics
and the roots of this european union is
less vivid
than for the founding fathers
but
but
we need this europe
and probably your generation much more
than the former ones
first because we have a series of huge
challenges and your prime minister the
alaska described part of them and i i
fully concur with your introduction
but if you look at the situation
we are in
our globalization
is in a huge crisis
and this crisis
is mirrored
in a big european crisis
crisis because of
the race of new challenges and because
of the inability of this globalization
present precisely to
monitor its own consequences
you have a huge demographic crisis
in africa
with direct impact on europe
but in the eastern world in america as
well when you look at the situation
between mexico and the us everywhere in
the world we have a demographic issue
due to birth rates lack of education
creating migration and political crisis
between the different regions
you have a huge
environment in climate crisis
because of the consequences of our
current globalization
and the indirect effects of it the way
to produce
which will force us to create a new way
to produce a new way to organize
ourselves
and you have a huge technological and
digital challenge
totally disrupting the way to produce
but as well as a way to consume to
behave yourself
and to create your new environment and
artificial intelligence is part of
this new revolution
with a lot of consequences and we can
revert on it
during the discussion
and probably a fourth challenge
dealing with inequalities
because this word based on
short-term cycles acceleration of
innovations
finance
over-concentrated
successes in
some small part of the world
and
created
some legends in big difficulties and
created increased inequalities within
our societies and between societies
these four challenges are putting our
democracies at risk
all our democracies were based
on a sort of
consensus
where we had protection
of liberties and individual rights
values
rights of the individual
progress for middle classes
and
a social
free market
everything is being put at risk because
of the fact that middle classes have no
new
opportunities in this environment and
because of this overall crisis
and that's why what we are seeing is the
race of illiberal democracies
of the oppresses
new regimes
and 20 years ago
in front of you people like us probably
would have spoken about the end of
history
the fact that peace will be spread out
of the world
and that democracies will win the party
but even now within europe it's no more
the case because of this crisis
and europe is a way to address these
challenges
neither denmark nor france
will fix the inequality issue the
climate issue or the demographic issue
is a technological issue i mean it's
impossible
on this items china and u.s
are proposing a whole i mean their model
their role model
totally different
but europe is a unique continent to have
a certain
[Music]
checks and balances i would say
attachment to liberty
attachment to equality in the same time
and
attachment to culture education and a
series of values which made ourselves
if we don't
decide
to create a new momentum for europe
what will happen
other people
big corporates
all the powers will decide for ourselves
in order to try to fix these issues
also i will lose the battles
on these critical challenges
and
this path i want to propose
and
the project we can have for europe and
the european union
is to try to make our european union our
own model to fix these four challenges
let's create
a new power
in order to educate our people a new
power of development
vis-a-vis africa with a new new deal
with africa let's create the most
innovative region of the world in order
to fix the climate issue
it's about renewables about co2 pricing
but a lot of other issues we can refer
them
let's create the leader of artificial
intelligence and technology it's
feasible in europe if we don't do so it
will be created in the us
by large corporates
without any state regulation or by
chinese with actual regulations but not
exactly ours
and the same relationship with
individual liberty freedom and privacy
and let's create a europe
with
social environmental and tax convergence
an actual economic and social poor which
could be the role model in order to make
this world sustainable
these issues are not just our internal
issues
it's part of the domestic debate in
denmark it's exactly the same in france
what we have to propose for the upcoming
european elections but what we have to
propose more largely
is precisely this big change for europe
this is not a way to manage or monitor
our european union your generation will
be a generation of new founding fathers
there is no other choice
because the world
is at the crossroads
so let's do it and we can revert
on
all these challenges and all the
solutions
in detail we propose and i would like to
promote
but
what i just wanted to focus on and
highlight for this introduction
is that
there is no choice you didn't decide to
be here now
but your generation we will have to deal
with a very critical moment of our world
my conviction
is that this moment
will push us to decide
to take some risks
sometime
to take some very bold decisions
but the main risk is not to take anyone
the main risk is to accept the authors
to decide for ourselves
that's why i do believe that europe we
will have to invent for the coming
months and years
is based on the one we have but has to
be in depth
reinvented
with a lot of ambition
with a lot of energy
and with our commitment thanks very much
and i'm not 100 sure that we'll be able
to talk about all the points that you
both mentioned but uh let's try at least
sort of to have a good start and let's
move right down here i see young lady
yes please stand up thank you
mr president thank you so much for being
here and taking your time to
we can ask our questions um my name is
emily and i'm a student here at the
copenhagen university where i study
political science
i was wondering yesterday
you told your ambassadors that
europe could no longer rely on u.s for
its security
and recently the german foreign minister
said that we need to form a
counterweight to washington because of
the cooling eu-us relations
so now that you're in denmark
how do you see our opportunities as a
small state to to act in this to
strengthen strengthen our ties to the eu
and to german and france
without stepping on trump's toes and
making making him leave nato or making
our security more risky so yeah how do
we act in this new world order or
disorder maybe
hold that thought
because now we go to sylgaba
and here we have cecilia cox and she
would like to ask a question about
brexit do you think there's going to be
a domino effect
with other countries leaving the eu
after brexit so now we have how do we
react towards the us and avoid stepping
on president trump's toes and we have
brexit and we have another question over
here
yes please yeah if you just stand up
then we have the microphone
mr president and mr prime minister
ashanti
my name is i'm sorry i studied french i
had to say
i just finished my bachelor's degree in
french at the university of copenhagen
and now i am in intercultural market
studies in a master
and actually i did my bachelor project
on your suburban speech
so
i've heard your say a lot you can be
french and you can be
well uh european or i guess it could be
danish and european for my case i would
like to ask a question
about
how can you facilitate a common
european meeting point between
all these different identities without
compromising our national identities i
think identity is
a key thing
in making the future europe
so thank you thank you very much and
then i see yes please just stand up yeah
lady in a blue wonderful jacket
almost like say hello yeah whatever yeah
flawless
thank you mr president mr prime minister
i have a pr i have a question for you mr
president i was actually in your
hometown i'm young this summer where i
saw
the tour de france
and i remember that it was very very hot
as it has been very very hot here in
denmark this summer
so my question is about climate change
and
you write in your book revolution
that
climate change is one of the most
important issues of our times to to
tackle and you just mentioned it as well
in your speech
so um
i would like to know starting with
yourself
what have you and your wife done at home
in order to become more climate uh
friendly
and second of all what do you see as the
biggest challenge on the global scene in
order to do something about climate
change thank you
i think we have enough on our plate here
so climate change national identity
brexit and united states who would like
to go first
please please you don't have to answer
all of them please because we have oh on
another sort of uh
services
i will try to
to answer
at least
part of the questions as for um defense
issue and
our relationship with them with u.s and
european defense
i think your country is a great country
in terms of defense
this morning i paid tribute to your
soldiers
and when you compare your population to
the people you lost on the battleground
in afghanistan and some others
i mean
it's incredible
and you pay the tribute
and i think and we had this discussion
at the last nato meeting when you when
you speak about
contribution to defensive fault
i think it's
it's incorrect just speak about money we
speak about our people
our soldiers
and your soldiers were part of this
defaults and what we did and what we are
doing in mali today and sale
in afghanistan and some other places
that's a very first one you are here and
you're part of this european defense
now i'm deeply convinced we have to do
more at the european level we we've just
passed a law in france in order to
increase our efforts and go to the
two-person gdp no because
nato asked for the two-person gdp it was
a commitment i took vis-a-vis the french
people because i think
in this current environment with a huge
technical technological change with new
threats
with terrorist threats we have basically
to be better organized and invest
in a new generation for our defense
and i
i do believe
that this kind of effort has to be made
at the european level
i i believe in nato
and i think it's very useful and
important that nato was created
during the cold war
and there is no more
the past enemy
i mean
what pushed us and triggered the
creation of nato is no more here ussr is
no more here you have russia but we
don't have the same relationship with
russia
so obviously nato is useful with new
risks but
the implicit deal between european
members european countries and the us
which is de facto u.s was paying and was
protecting europe
is probably less valid today than during
the cold war which means that europe
needs this wake-up call
and europe needs
a natural autonomy an actual
independence
and actual sovereignty from a different
point of view
that's why we took a series of decisions
at the european level
during the past year in order to create
new cooperation a new fund and now a new
initiative and denmark joined this
initiative which is part of this new
european sovereignty in terms of defense
and for me it's not something against
the us absolutely not
it's something for us
we need it
and we need it as well to be credible
vis-a-vis the u.s
so i think it's very important and the
more we can contribute you have this
opt-out issue it's something to be
debated from a domestic point of view
this is a sovereign issue for you
but i think so the decision you took in
this framework already are very clear
and very strong and very important to me
in such a context
as for brexit i think if we don't
monitor properly brexit we can have a
domino effect one of our obsession
and one of our top priority is first
respect the vote
of british voters obviously
but in the same time to respect all the
other citizens of the rest of europe
we didn't decide to kill the european
union
so which means we have absolutely to
avoid any domino effects
which means
we have to preserve
our four freedoms
and the solidarity of the four freedoms
we have to preserve
the integrity of the single market and
the european union
and for me it's part of the common
position we have together and today we
have a very good organization we
discussed among 27th but we have one
negotiator and one common position
precisely to avoid that
your question about identities is a very
important one
i'm a strong believer in europe
but i never defended the ideas that
there is in a certain way
a sort of european people making
disappear
the national people
it doesn't exist
and when you look at the global
situation today you have
a resurgence of national identities and
identities of people
but i'm
deeply convinced that our actual
identity
boss donation french but it's true for
the rest of europe
it's not just a national identity
we are always and already both
danish and french and european it's
through
through some personal
life and stories and
you have a beautiful case with a royal
family in this country
this is not totally a
danish story
but it's true for everybody
the actual danish
doesn't exist it's already european and
it's true for french people
and let me give you
some of the way to embody in a certain
way this reality
you have erasmus
european experience
you have
european universities we were discussing
about that and universities applied
for a european program to be part with
montpellier dublin and some others of a
european program which is a european
experience
but even your language is not just
danish
it's part of the european language
european language is not esperanto and
not english whatever we are doing now
just continue just to can you
go on
the european language and um have this
very beautiful sentence
is translation
and there is no actual french people
without the way to speak
in other languages
and there is no actual european language
being totally
i would say
closed
and blocked
in his home language
europe is made by these exchanges and
interactions there was a very beautiful
writer of the 18th century in france
madame de stall
and
she wrote several novels and
one book called the mind and she spoke
very well
um german and a lot of other languages
and she had this very beautiful formula
saying
when i don't find a word
in french
i'm sure to find it in german
or in english
and that's exactly the european story
and that's why i do believe
that what you are doing what we are
doing is just
to say we have a national identity we
have even a family identity
but this identity because we are
european
is not just the national one
there is no look at the map
there is no other region in the world
with such a diversity of languages
of people
of diversity and climate change
climate change
i have to say we are doing some
investment at the elizabeth because now
we are there but before joining we made
an investment in the house
for windows
precisely in order to reduce
the electricity cost
window of opportunity for climate change
no but because it's i mean and that's
how to reconcile climate and economy
uh uh
as for
for me it's the most important global
it's co2 emission
i mean obviously you have biodiversity
oceans and so on but you ask me for one
co2 emission
which means
on mobility on companies on our way to
produce electricity we have to make a
big change
and such a strategy we are we are
dealing at the national level deciding
to close
all the coal plants
which is number one
source of emission
a big mobility plan and we increase the
price for
gasoline
which is not very popular i can tell i
can tell you but it's a necessity
that's what we have to do now at the
european level with the co2 pricing an
actual single market and at the global
level it's part of the climate change
the time at paris agreement
but platform is a very top one because
that's
the origin
of precisely what you experienced during
your summer in emea and and in
copenhagen with this new temperatures
and by the way i'm i'm happy you you saw
the tour de france in namia and i'm
happy to to see
in the coming years the tour de france
in copenhagen
now you're talking
well
i think i believe in myself to a few
comments will there be a domino effect
after brexit that's exactly the same
question and the very first question uh
raised by donald trump when i first met
him in the white house
and i couldn't really figure out whether
he was hopeful or yeah or whatever
enlighten us come on but but but my
answer was a clear no uh
but i agree with the manual it it it
obviously links to the way we we we deal
with this and and and the solution and
that's just an additional reason why we
have to strike a balance between
obligations and
and
and
right so to speak
i do not fear domino effect because if
you look to uk these days
it is obvious that they are starting to
suffer from it
and i'm pleased to say that if you ask
the danes they are more pro-europe now
than before the referendum i think
brexit is a
reminder
of what we have taken for granted
10 of the danish gdp is directly linked
to our participation in the single
market
so i mean
there's no way we should leave the
european union but at the same time we
have to take seriously what you ask
about about national identity
and that's why i'm in favor of striking
a balance
where we use the european union to solve
big problems
and where we leave small things to
nations
we need this kind of how should i put it
a
peaceful
competition between countries i mean we
haven't solved all problems in denmark
but but i mean the scandinavian model
have been successful in many ways for
instance in your opening remarks
emmanuel you talked about
the fact that
inequality
could lead to a situation where people
turn their backs towards globalization
and of course we have issues in denmark
as well but i think we have been
together with sweden and other countries
better than many other countries to
redistribute prosperity among ourselves
and and for that reason the danes are
open towards the rest of the world and
towards changes
so i think we should
we should and that would be an ongoing
discussion and we will disagree and we
will agree and we have to find a
compromise because
we shouldn't you know leave everything
to europe and and and on the other hand
we should understand that sovereignty is
not about taking all decisions by
ourselves
um that's a balance
and then
just a few words about nato and and and
and defense i mean
we need this debate in denmark and
that's why i have called for this debate
uh we both witnessed uh a
summit a nato summit a few months ago a
few weeks ago
i'm not the one
who should
give all the details about
our internal discussions
but
i just want to say that i share your
opinion that
participation is not only about how much
money do you spend it's also about your
readiness to stand up
and at least i use the opportunity to
tell the
american president in
in a very clear voice that we will not
accept
that we are judged only by our
expenditures i mean we have had exactly
as many casualties in afghanistan as the
americans and we always stand up
so
that's not acceptable
but we have to realize that this is not
only about trump of course trump
put it his way and
slightly different from what we have
experienced in the past
but there's a reason why he was elected
and i think we have to take seriously
that
u.s in general
expect that we take a great
responsibility for our own security
so that's why i define nato as a
cornerstone but at the same time we have
to do more
in the european framework
we have this opt-out and it can't be
removed without a referendum i'm not
going for referendum today but we have
to discuss it
and in the meanwhile with full respect
of the opt-out denmark need to
participate in a european framework as
well and that's why we have closed this
deal or agreed that we should enhance
our bilateral cooperation and i don't
think that will provoke
the american president quite the
opposite actually because they actually
demand from us
that we do more so if we respond by
doing more there's no reason why they
should react in a negative way
thank you very much uh time is running
out unfortunately but i have a question
here from sunnyball
basically asking both of you and if you
could do it sort of snappy way
so
how can we improve the cooperation on
migration between our two countries
migration being obviously very important
issue also if you want to have a europe
that protects
one minute each is that possible
i would want to use 30 of my seconds
no
look
migration
is a challenge not just for this year or
the year to come but for decades
first point
second
we need to articulate responsibility and
solidarity
so the way to proceed is not to be
simplistic or nationalistic
no issue on a national basis is sure
and look at the nationalistic approach
what they propose is against the author
but they never manage to coordinate
between each other
so what we have to do better cooperation
and more development with origin
countries especially in africa
more cooperation against smugglers with
trans countries what we launched one
year ago first with some of them
more investment on our common protection
common frontiers with frantics what we
propose and i think we totally agree on
that common organization
for countries of arrivals with more
solidarity with these control centers
and and and solidarity
distinction between asylum and economic
migration asylum is a duty no discussion
economic migration is to be discussed
and some people have to come back and
six
common regulation to have solidarity
between the other member states between
origin country and the others not on the
basis of quota because qatar doesn't fly
but basics on willingness approach for
those who can get asylum
financial contribution to some of these
countries
but a common regulation
and you do me a favor you just say you
agree yeah excellent brilliant thank you
very much mr prime minister because time
is running out and uh i have people here
looking very sort of strict at me and
you know it's your program yes yeah it's
my program and we can't arrive
so basically i agree thank you very much
mr prime minister good well yeah
[Applause]
i can't let you leave mr president
keep you here anyway but uh you have to
leave um but i have to thank you
yeah yeah basically i wanted to give you
a present
we thought about giving you an umbrella
when we watched the uh world cup
ceremony in moscow uh but then i know
sort of your colleague here so he has
obviously made sure that you have an
umbrella if it rains so we decided upon
something else
we started with certain kierkegaard and
now we will go full circle when you came
to the royal library you saw the
original manuscripts of search here go
so let's also end with sir and kirikou
so this is sir kirkuk so please accept
sir and here you go as a present from
the library the university of copenhagen
and the artist
heisen and remember and i presume this
goes for presidents and prime ministers
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lift forwards thank you
very much for coming mr president
thank you
so ladies and gentlemen
president of france prime minister of
denmark
please our rise for his royal highness
and please remain
in the venue until our guests have left
the building thank you very much
[Applause]
so
foreign